on this friday night manitoba's covid
crisis
the province sends an sos to the feds
and a plea to the public
even if you're well stay home as the
rest of the country
starts to turn a corner the debate over
resuming
in-person learning is this the best time
to bring kids back
as one province gets set to send
students back to the classroom
peace for now in the middle east how
both hamas and israel
are claiming victory and the lost
sounds of gore downing
the new album from the tragically hip
and its beloved front man
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening glad to be with
you tonight
the may long weekend is finally upon us
this one a more optimistic one
while the pandemic might not yet be over
and much of canada's still
under tough restrictions there are some
encouraging signs of where our country
is headed
over the last seven days daily cases
dropped more than 25 percent
and the national vaccination rate is
climbing fast nearly 49
of canadians have now had at least one
dose
at the same time few people have been
fully vaccinated
and with the virus still spreading
public health officials are urging
everyone to be careful
and follow the rules this holiday
weekend
our actions this long weekend could not
be more important
covert 19 resurgences have followed
social gatherings during past holidays
and long weekends
there is one province where that message
is more critical than any other
manitoba it's dealing with the highest
infection rate
in canada right now the situation in
hospitals so severe
that premier brian pallister called the
prime minister to ask for help
eric sorenson has tonight's top story
five manitoba covid patients are now
hundreds of kilometers from home in
intensive care at hospitals in northern
ontario
including thunder bay the transfer was
necessary because manitoba is running
out of icu beds
one er doctor describes the situation as
dire
it's the worst i've ever seen we are at
pretty much 100
capacity without the ability at the
moment to take
more cases the rate of daily covet cases
is almost two and a half times that of
ontario
beleaguered premier brian pallaster
spoke with the prime minister today
he requested up to 50 critical care
nurses plus other personnel
our health system is is on the brink
of being overwhelmed the contingency
plans are being triggered
a ban on social gatherings even outdoors
will only go into effect
at midnight tonight winnipeg's mayor
says the province has been too slow to
act
i think the time to act with strong
proactive measures
were weeks ago today a simple message to
manitobans that it's serious
if you're sick stay home even if you're
well
stay home the continuing rise of cases
in manitoba does not reflect what's
happening in most of the country
in other western provinces next week
british columbia will announce its
reopening plans
alberta wants students to return to
in-class learning
and saskatchewan will reopen restaurants
if certain vaccine targets are met
in ontario golfers will be on the links
starting saturday
in quebec curfews will end may 28th one
week from now
and the east coast hopes to open the
atlantic bubbles somewhat as early as
next month
newfoundland and labrador is considering
opening to all canadians
by july the first canada day in short
much of the country is turning the
corner this toronto golf course got word
yesterday it could open
the phone started ringing people got
excited
the emails were constant experts believe
it won't be long before all provinces
can be more synchronized in opening up
as vaccines start to go out in a
widespread way
i think we will all be synced at a point
at some point
in the summer time where we all have
very very low community transmission
manitoba has that to look forward to but
for now
we need to suffer a little bit longer
so we can turn this curve eric sorensen
global news
toronto next door ontario is resuming
the use of the astrazeneca vaccine for
people who received it for their first
dose
data shows the risk of blood clots is
even more rare after a second dose
approximately one in a million
and with tens of thousands of doses set
to expire in ontario
the province is allowing some people to
opt in early
michael couture reports now we are
confident we can now offer a second dose
of astrazeneca
vaccine ontario's top doctor may be
confident but not everyone
is sherry langer got her first dose of
astrazeneca between march 10th
and 19th so she would be eligible to get
a second dose
but she's holding out for an mrna
vaccine
i won't wait indefinitely but hopefully
that the information will be there for
me to make
a really good informed decision for the
best
protection now preliminary research on
vaccine mixing
is promising canadian health officials
are anxiously awaiting
a uk report on combining a viral vector
vaccine
with an mrna which is expected to be out
in early june but there remain
approximately 55 000 doses of
astrazeneca
in ontario waiting to go into arms
doses are going to expire and it would
be a complete tragedy to not fully
vaccinate people if they could be fully
vaccinated
to administer them before they expire
ontario will be shortening the interval
between
doses from 16 weeks to in some cases
10 weeks the manufacturer's recommended
interval
is 12 weeks it's fairly negligible at
this stage here
and so we think it's fine to use the 10
to 12 weeks many countries like uk we're
down to eight weeks
all provinces stopped administering
astrazeneca as a first dose but most
continue to offer it as a second one
prince edward island and newfoundland in
labrador are waiting for guidance
from the national advisory committee on
immunization
doctors believe many will jump at the
chance of getting a second dose
but sherry langer won't they can't cover
everybody at this point anyway
what's best for me is waiting at this
point she'll keep waiting
and watching the evolving science of
vaccines
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
there has been another
astrazeneca-linked death in this country
a new brunswicker has died from a rare
blood clot disorder associated with the
vaccine
the person who was in their 50s went to
hospital with symptoms 17
days after receiving the shot there have
been more than 20 confirmed blood clot
cases
in canada linked to the astrazeneca
vaccine more than 2 million doses have
been administered across the country
four people have died in alberta today
was the last day of online learning for
most students
the province still has the highest
active coven 19
case rate in our country but schools
across much of alberta
will resume in-person classes next week
ontario's top doctor says he'd like to
see schools there reopen soon as well
heather urux west looks at the benefits
and the risks of sending kids
back to class for this edmonton family
nothing about the last year has been
constant
or routine i find it such a roller
coaster for them their emotions they go
back and then all of a sudden over sent
home
do i have everything alberta students
head back to the classroom
in person on tuesday schools moved
online across alberta in early may
but with surging case numbers some
schools including those in calgary's
catholic school district
asked the province to close in person
classes back in april
finding out schools reopening so quickly
took the district's superintendent by
surprise i defer to the experts who have
made this decision but
i think i also speak on behalf of many
parents many of our staff members
that are also questioning like you know
is this the best time to bring kids back
canada's third wave has hit young people
and kids harder than the previous two
still this pediatric emergency room
doctor supports getting kids back to
class
i think it's a good move i think
probably if you had asked me actually i
would say it wasn't a great move to take
them out of the classrooms
across canada some students are back in
classrooms already
in bc at most schools in-person learning
has never stopped
in saskatchewan regina area students
returned to classrooms in early may
while most quebec high school students
return at the end of the month
ontario's top doctor says he'd like
schools to reopen
in june though the premier says others
want the province to wait
it could possibly increase cases by 11
percent
that's concerning with me the school
year is not over
yet but a summer filled with
vaccinations will make things a lot
better by
fall heather urex west global news
calgary
canada has extended its ban on incoming
flights from india and pakistan by
another month
the ban was implemented on april 22nd
and will now expire on june 21st
it applies to direct flights from both
countries the federal transportation
minister says the measures
have reduced the risk of importing cases
and new variants a ceasefire between
israel and hamas appears to be holding
tonight
11 days of fighting killed more than 250
people and caused extensive damage
the vast majority in gaza today many
palestinians in the enclave return
to what is left of their homes entire
families searching through the debris
hoping to salvage some items israelis
also have a respite from the fear of
attack israel and hamas are both
claiming victory but as redmond shannon
explains
the clash between police and worshipers
at the al-aqsa mosque shows
this truce is very fragile
celebrations of the cease-fire after
friday prayers
but the mood at al-aqsa mosque soon
turned
a familiar corner tear gas and rubber
bullets from police
rocks from some worshipers it's unclear
what
triggered the skirmishes in gaza there
was peace
but also a grim reality many residents
returning to where they
used to live
this woman said this truce is only good
for those who have homes
where are we supposed to go gazan
authorities say
65 children there were killed that
figure
is two in israel
that contrast didn't stop a hamas leader
declaring a strategic victory
the palestinians believe that for the
first time they've broken israel's
monopoly on the narrative
and that the world is finally taking
note and listening to the palestinian
narrative and following palestinian
social media
that has enabled them to bypass
mainstream media
benjamin netanyahu still clinging on to
his job as
israeli leader claimed victory too
describing the campaign as an
outstanding success
that degraded hamas ability to attack
israel
it's important for him that he wanted to
make the show of force
to remind the israelis to say look you
have an enemy sitting on your border i'm
the one who's been protecting you
but the threat of a new conflict remains
very real
hamas doesn't recognize israel's right
to exist
we have no plans to change our security
assistance
that we're providing to israel a
resolution from u.s senator bernie
sanders to block a huge arms sale to
israel
is unlikely to pass but it does indicate
the rising number of democrats voicing
concern for the scale of u.s support for
israel
something the israeli government will at
least be taking note of
when making its next move redmond
shannon global news
london home prices hitting the roof
coming up how young canadians are
feeling blocked from the booming real
estate market
plus angry birds when danger lurks above
it's officially swooping season in
vancouver trees and traffic lights are
again prime real estate for some
aggressive crows
so if you're walking with your head in
the clouds remember
these big birds get very protective
around their nests in the spring and
summer
and they have terrifying dive bombing
skills
global news is launching a new series
called priced out
looking at housing affordability for
young canadians there is a growing
cohort
under the age of 35 who feel their
dreams of homeownership
are becoming out of reach because they
just can't afford it
and the bank of canada issued a warning
this week saying household debt
especially mortgages
leaves many households vulnerable in
case there is a significant financial
change
in their future like rising interest
rates or job loss
our senior business correspondent ann
gaviola joins us now ann
farah this warning comes as new tougher
mortgage stress test rules are set to
kick in next week these are going to
reduce affordability for those looking
to buy a first home
and many millennials have been priced
out
it's really disheartening 29 year
twenty-nine-year-old patty tracy has
been house hunting for nearly two years
even with a six-figure household income
getting into the market seemed tough
pre-pandemic
but now his income has taken a hit and
with prices on a tear
and extreme bidding war is the norm home
ownership seems even further out of
reach for him and his fiancee
we were looking and the houses in guelph
a year ago were
four hundred five hundred thousand
dollars
now they're like six hundred to eight
hundred thousand dollars a year later
how does that happen he joins a growing
cohort of young people who feel priced
out of a market that's become
even hotter a report this month from
national bank of canada says the average
down payment for a home in toronto
would take nearly a quarter century for
a household making 180
000 a year to save and more than 30
years for a place in vancouver
the bank of mom and dad is a factor too
according to a recent td bank survey
about half of millennial buyers
say they rely on parents to chip in
financially for home ownership
that's a stark increase from two decades
ago when parental help was used towards
14 percent of down payments the majority
of households have prospered during the
pandemic
couple that with historically low
mortgage rates and a desire for more
space
it's the recipe for an ultra competitive
housing market
inequality has been growing in canada
for about 30 years
and within that same period
and governments at all levels have been
little on the house front
the covet economic downturn has
solidified the fortunes of homeowners
while taking a disproportionate toll on
renters
seems unsustainable and yet that's what
we
say every couple years like this is a
bubble it's going to burst
and then it somehow doesn't if you're
wondering whether buying or renting is
the best path for you personal finance
experts point to the 5
rule take the total value of the home
you're looking to purchase
multiply it by 5 and divide it by 12
months
if you can rent for less than that then
renting may be your best bet
that decision of whether to rent or to
buy is obviously a deeply personal one
and in the next installment of priced
out next friday
i'll be looking into the stigma
associated with renting for life
and the impact that that has on those
who are struggling to get into the
housing market
farah and gaviola and toronto thanks ann
did you kill your wife next a bc man
breaks his silence on a years-long
mystery
you're watching global national
it was a death that rocked a quiet
corner of bc's beautiful
okanagan valley arlene westervelt's body
was pulled from okanagan lake after
canoeing with her husband burt
in 2016. but was it a tragic drowning
or a cold-blooded killing nearly five
years later what really happened to the
56-year-old nurse is still
bitterly disputed leaving her husband
and her family
poisoned by bad blood and accusations of
murder
here's global's jules knox
what happened between burt and arlene
westervelt on okanogan lake on june 26
2016 is shrouded in mystery
the couple spent the day paddling and
picnicking
when their canoe tipped and arlene died
her sisters
immediately called foul play i just
screamed it out he killed her he killed
her i know he killed her
i knew it but burt said
his wife drowned and investigators
appeared to believe him
arlene's death was treated as an
accident at first
the first conversation i had at the
coroner i begged him and pleaded with
him to do an autopsy
and he said there wasn't going to be an
autopsy and there wasn't
until days later when a divorce lawyer
contacted police
to reveal information about their client
arlene
that prompted mounties to start a murder
investigation
and three years later bert westervelt
was charged with second-degree murder
just a total disbelief never ever
did i think it would get that far on the
advice of his lawyer
burt wouldn't talk about the details of
how arlene died
but he's always maintained his innocence
and he shared his story in an exclusive
interview with the new reality
it's been hell yeah but it's not just on
me
it's my friends my friend's family last
summer
in yet another twist in this
long-running drama
crown prosecutors announced the murder
charge was being stayed
without explanation that decision
outraged the hennig family
they still believe arlene was murdered
by her husband
and continue to call for justice and
make no mistake
we are not going away and we are not
going to give up
our fight the stay period is set to
expire in less than two months
and after that it's unlikely the case
against bert westervelt will ever be
revived
so we asked him about the circumstances
leading up to his wife's death
his answer to that question and much
more on our exclusive interview with him
for the new reality
and we'll reveal new details about how
the investigation into arlene
westervelt's death
started to go wrong almost immediately
after her body was pulled from the lake
farah jules thank you for that and we
look forward to seeing your full story
tomorrow night at 7 pm
on the new reality toronto's captain
is out still ahead an update on john
tavares's condition
after a collision during the playoffs
in sports there's always a risk of
injury and there was a scary moment
during last night's stanley cup playoffs
game
between the toronto maple leafs and the
montreal canadiens
the hit was right to the head leaf's
captain john tavares has been discharged
from the hospital but he's out
indefinitely after that accidental
needed ahead by montreal's cory perry
who is speeding by
tavares has a concussion but tweeted
today thanking the hockey community for
its support
and medical teams for helping him back
on his feet he says i look forward to
when i can wear the maple leaf on my
chest again
until then i'll be cheering on the boys
along with leaf's nation that's global
national for this friday night
i'm farin asser thank you for spending
part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is spirit canyon
near ibex valley in yukon we love seeing
your canada
so please keep sending us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
i hope you get some time to check out
some beautiful scenery in your part of
the country this long weekend
robin gill will be with you tomorrow
until next friday take care of
yourselves
and each other
[Music]
you